YOUR FREE INFOKIT
>> Sandra: THE FDA ADVISORY
BOARD IS REVIEWING THE PFIZER
BIONTECH VACCINE.
IF APPROVED THE FIRST SHOTS
COULD COME HOURS FROM NOW.
AN ARTICLE IN "NEW YORK
MAGAZINE"  WITH THE HEADLINE WE
HAD THE VACCINE THE WHOLE TIME.
DR. PETER HOTEZ IS DEAN OF THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL OF TROPICAL
MEDICINE AT BAYLOR AND
CO-DIRECTOR OF TEXAS CHILDREN’S
HOSPITAL.
ALWAYS GOOD TO TALK TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED THE MAKE
OF THAT HEADLINE WHEN WE SAW IT?
HOW COULD THERE POSSIBLY HAVE
BEEN A VACCINE FOR THIS THAT
ALREADY EXISTED?
>> WHAT HAPPENED IN 2003 THE
FIRST SARS EMERGED.
THE OTHER NAME FOR COVID-19 IS
SARS 2.
THE FIRST SARS EMERGED OUT OF
SOUTHERN CHINA IN 2003 AND
SPREAD TO TORONTO AND STOOD UP
A BIG U.S. PROGRAM UNDER THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION AND THROUGH
N.I.H. TO SUPPORT VACCINES FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
WE STARTED MAKING VACCINES
AGAINST THE SPIKE PROTEIN AND
THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT SHOWED THAT THE SPIKE
PROTEIN IS THE WEAK LINK IN
THIS VIRUS AND HOW ALL THE
CURRENT COVID-19 VACCINES
OPERATE.
SO THE IMPORTANT POINT HERE
WHEN MANY PEOPLE THINK THAT
THIS WAS A RUSHED PROGRAM, IT
WAS NOT.
IT IS ACTUALLY A PROGRAM 17
YEARS IN THE MAKING STARTING
BACK IN 2003.
>> Sandra: THAT’S REALLY GOOD
INFORMATION TO HAVE, RIGHT?
IN MASSACHUSETTS THE "NEW YORK
MAGAZINE"  REPORTS THE MODERNA
VACCINE DESIGN TOOK ALL OF ONE
WEEKEND.
IT WAS COMPLETED BEFORE CHINA
HAD EVEN ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WAS
TRANSMITTED FROM HUMAN-TO-HUMAN.
IT WAS SHIPPED TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH FOR THE
BEGINNING OF ITS PHASE ONE
CLINICAL TRIAL.
WHY WEREN’T WE TOLD THIS THEN?
OTHERWISE AND PART OF THE
PUBLIC WORRY ABOUT TAKING THE
VACCINE IS HOW FAST THIS HAS
GONE COMPARED TO OTHER VACCINE
APPROVALS.
SO WOULDN’T THIS BE GOOD
INFORMATION TO PUT OUT PUBLICLY
THAT THIS WAS ALREADY IN THE
WORKS?
>> I THINK THE SITUATION THERE
WAS BECAUSE THE RNA TECHNOLOGY
IS A BRAND-NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
NEVER RESULTED IN A LICENSED
VACCINE BEFORE PEOPLE DIDN’T
WANT TO OVERPROMISE OR RAISE
FALSE EXPECTATIONS.
WE DIDN’T KNOW HOW WELL IT
WOULD TURN OUT INTO A VACCINE.
A LOT OF US WERE SURPRISED.
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF OPERATION
WARP SPEED WAS TO CREATE AND
USE CUTTING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE RNA VACCINES AND A PROTEIN
VACCINE.
WE’RE SCALING UP PRODUCTION IN
INDIA.
THE OTHER PIECE IS WE DON’T
KNOW HOW DURABLE THE PROTECTION
WILL BE FOR THE RNA VACCINE.
WILL IT LAST THREE MONTHS,
THREE YEARS, 30 YEARS?
THE WISDOM OF THE OPERATION
WARP SPEED PROGRAM.
CREATE A PORTFOLIO AND GET AS
MANY SHOTS ON GOAL AS WE CAN.
>> Sandra: THE PUBLIC APPROVAL
HEARING IS HAPPENING NOW
WEIGHING IN ON THE PFIZER